UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL WILL- COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMPANY WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT TWO. SIX
EIGHT. FOUR TWO EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
WAR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
AND PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TRIAL LONDON ZERO. A FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT ON THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO COAL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU ARE YEAH
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE. THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S JUST RIP THAT
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEDIAN SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT. YOUR HEARING
CENTERS CLOSE TO SAME MANNERS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR THE PARTICIPANTS
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE SIX BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. WE BEFORE WE
HEAR THE PRESENTATION THE BILLS
LESS ESTABLISH A QUORUM TO HAVE
A QUORUM YET. NOT YET. WE WILL-
THE MOVE FORWARD AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. OF THE COMMITTEE
TO HEAR TESTIMONY. ON THE ON
THE BILLS START TODAY'S AGENDA.
OUR FIRST PRESENTER TODAY IS ON
ITEM ONE A. B. FOURTEEN FIVE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AGUILAR CURRY
RELATED TO BROADBAND SERVICES
WELCOME AND PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND MEMBERS. I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR OR VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
I HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
THE WORK TO ENSURE ONGOING
RESOURCES TO THE DOBSON. THE
CONSORTIUM ACCOUNTS. ONLY
TWENTY MILES FROM OUR STATE'S
CAPITAL IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY THERE ARE CALIFORNIANS
WHO HAVE NO ACCESS TO BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY. AND THE ESTIMATED
FINANCIAL NEED TO DEPLOY
BROADBAND IN THIS SMALL REGION
ALONE IS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THERE ARE
IN FACT CONNECTIVITY PROBLEMS
IN URBAN AND RURAL AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
TECHNOLOGY STATE. ONE IN EIGHT
CALIFORNIA HOMES STILL DO NOT
HAVE INTERNET ACCESS AND SMALL
TOWNS RURAL AREAS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FACE EVEN
HIGHER NUMBERS OF STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES REMAIN DISCONNECTED.
UNDER CURRENT STANDARDS AND THE
FCC IS CONSIDERING RAISING
THOSE STANDARDS AS WE SPEAK.
FURTHERMORE THE ONGOING HOBART
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS MADE IT
GLARINGLY IT'S CLEAR HOW
CRITICAL CONNECTIVITY IN TIMES
OF EMERGENCIES INCLUDING THE
MASSIVE TRANSITION OF STUDENTS
LEARNING FROM HOME. AND DURING
THE STATE'S RECENT DEVASTATING
FIRES. YEAH XCELERATED NEED FOR
BROADBAND CANNOT BE IGNORED.
THAT IS WHY I'M PARTNERING WITH
SENATOR LENA GONZALES AND TWO
DOZEN OF OUR HOLDINGS INCLUDING
SENATOR EMINENT AND SENATOR
TO ADDRESS THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
IN THE STATE. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OVER THE PAST MONTHS WE WORKED
TOGETHER ON A LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE THAT WILL MODERNIZE
STANDARDS ADOPTED THEM AS THE
FCC STANDARDS EVOLVE PUT UP NEW
SPEEDS AND TECHNOLOGY. OUR
BILLS BOTH PROVIDING
ELIGIBILITY FOR K. CALIFORNIA
ADVANCE SERVICES FUND FUNDING.
AT TWENTY FIVE DOWNLOAD THREE
UPLOAD WITH BUILD UP AT A
HUNDRED TWENTY. AB FOURTEEN
PRIORITIZES THE DEPLOYMENT OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE.
ON AND UNDERSERVED RURAL AND
URBAN AREAS WHILE OPENING THE
DOOR FOR OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE CONNECTIVITY IN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITIES WHERE THE
PRIVATE SECTOR CANNOT. OR
CHOOSES NOT TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT SERVICE. MAYBE
FOURTEEN PROVIDES FOR AN
EXTENSION OF THE SURCHARGE ON
THE TELECOM SERVICE. WELL THE
CPUC WOULD CONSIDER THE EXACT
METHOD FOR EXTENDING THAT
SURCHARGE. WE ANTICIPATE THAT
WIRELINE. AGAIN WIRELINE
CUSTOMERS P. WELL ACTUALLY
DECREASE. MY BILL INSURANCE
GRANTS ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AWARDED TO
APPLICANTS WERE WILLING. AND
ABLE TO QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY
CONNECT HOUSEHOLDS COMMUNITY
BANKER INSTITUTIONS SMALL
BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYERS BY
MAKING ELIGIBLE ANCHOR
INSTITUTIONS ALONG THE PATHWAY
FOR PROJECT SO WE DON'T MISS
OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDE LINKAGES
TO HEALTH. EDUCATION PUBLIC AND
PUBLIC SAFETY AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE FACILITIES. MEMBERS
I'VE BEEN WORKING FOR OVER A
DECADE STARTING AS MAYOR OF A
SMALL TOWN BY SMALL TOWN
WINTERS CALIFORNIA TO FIX FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE A LACK OF
VITAL INFRASTRUCTURE MADE
PAINFULLY OBVIOUS BY THE
PANDEMIC. TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS
HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND THEY TEND
TO BE THOSE MOST OF NEED OF
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET TO
SUPPORT THEIR HEALTH CARE TO
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES
EDUCATION AND JOB TRAINING.
PORT THE MAJORITY OF SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO WORK FROM HOME
TRYING TO COMPETE IN TODAY'S
DIGITAL ECONOMY. A GREAT MANY
OF US WORKING ON DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THIS FIGHT. TOGETHER
WE'VE BUILT THE MOMENTUM TO
SUCCEED THIS YEAR NOW IS THE
TIME TO SEIZE THE MOMENT AND
BRING ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
FURTHER WORK HEALTH AND QUALITY
OF LIFE. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. IS TRISH KELLY ON
BEHALF OF VALLEY VISION AND A
WATER GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY REGIONAL
BROADBAND CONSORTIUM. AND
FRESNO STATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BEFORE WE PROCEED I JUST
WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR TO THE
PUBLIC THAT AMENDMENTS WERE
PROPOSED AND I JUST WANTED TO-
GET THE AUTHOR TO IGNORE H. IF.
YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS HERE. ABSOLUTELY M.
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VERY MUCH I WILL HEAR
NOW FROM THE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. WE WILL GRAB THREE
MINUTES FOR THE SUPPORT
PRESENTATION SOUL DIVIDE THE
THREE MINUTES INTO EACH SPEAKER
EACH SPEAKER HAS A MINUTE AND A
HALF BEGINNING WITH EDUARDO
GONZALEZ. FROM CSU FRESNO MR
GONZALEZ- WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME FOR
THE LOT OF ON SITE IS
REPRESENTING THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY FRESNO WHICH
ADMINISTERS THE FOUNTAIN VALLEY
REGIONAL BROADBAND
CONSTRUCTION. AS MENTIONED
BEFORE ONE IN A CALIFORNIA HOME
STILL DO NOT HAVE INTERNET
ACCESS IN THE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS OUR CONSORTIA WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OTHER REGIONAL
CONSORTIA LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS
AND PARTNERS HAVE IDENTIFIED
HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
LIMITED OR NO ACCESS TO
BROADBAND. JUST IN OUR REGION
CAN YOU BELIEVE SIXTY FOUR
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS WERE
IDENTIFIED THESE HOUSEHOLDS ARE
BOTH URBAN AND RURAL LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS. MAKING THE
BROADBAND DIGITAL DIVIDE IN
CALIFORNIA AN EQUITY ISSUE
TODAY I'M HERE TO ASK FOR AND I
BOTH SUPPORT A B. FOURTEEN AS A
STRATEGIC SOLUTION TO CONNECT
TO STUDENTS. FAMILIES BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO REMAIN DISCONNECTED
UNDER CURRENT STANDARDS IF
BROADBAND HAD A TIME IT IS NOW
AND HOW CAN WE FIX CALIFORNIA'S
BROADBAND YOU WITH MINIMAL
FUNDED AND CONTINUES BARRIERS
TO DEPLOYMENT CREATED BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS. OF WHERE THEY LIVE
DEMOGRAPHICS HOUSEHOLD INCOME
ARE ENTITLED TO THE SAME
PRIVILEGES THANK YOU AND I HAVE
WORKED IN ONLINE EDUCATION AND
ADEQUATE BROADBAND SPEED
APPARENTLY THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR BELIEVES.
BECAUSE THIS IS WHERE A B.
FOURTEEN COMES TO PLAY OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE CONNECTIVITY
TO THEIR OWN TWO MEETINGS WITH
THE PRIVATE SECTOR CANNOT OR
CHOOSE NOT TO COLLECT
SUFFICIENT SERVICE.
CONDITIONALLY UP MENTION AT
FOURTEEN CHURCH GRANTS
ADMINISTERED BY C. P. ZERO ONE
O'CLOCK. WE'RE WILLING AND ABLE
TO QUICKLY EFFICIENTLY CONNECT
HOUSEHOLDS COMMUNITY ANCHOR
INSTITUTIONS SMALL BUSINESS
EMPLOYERS WHAT LAST MILE
CONNECTIVITY AND FOR THOSE
REASONS. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT MICHAEL. THANK YOU ME FOR
WEEKS AGO ON TO THE SPEAKER OF
WHEN I. OR SECRETARY TO- CALL
THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH FORM. AND
STUFF THAT- WESSEL. RESIDENTS
WESSEL PRESENCE BY THIRD ALLEY
HERE ALI HERE BECKER. FACTOR
HERE MARGE'S. FORTIS PRESENTS
BRADFORD YOUR RECORD HERE DOT.
DOT HERE AIKMAN. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ HERE. HELLO HERTZBERG.
MCGUIRE MAN PRESIDENT MAN
PRESENCE WILL BE A- STERN. WELL
WE HAVE A QUORUM. WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT BAKER- TRISH KELLY
FROM VALLEY VISION YOU HAVE ONE
HALF MINUTES WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR DEDICATED LEADERSHIP TO
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
THANK YOU SENATOR CONSULT FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP FUND AT
FOURTEEN. TELEVISION MANAGES
THE CONNECTED CAPITAL AREA
BROADBAND CONSORTIUM IN THE
CAPITAL REGION SO WE ARE YOU
HAVE A MISSION TO CONNECT 98%
OF THE HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED AS UNSERVED THAT
SAID MARGO MENTIONS THEY HAVE A
HUGE NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS IN
THEIR REGION IN OUR REGION WE
HAVE MORE THAN THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND. ONE THIRD HELPFUL AND
WE KNOW THE NUMBER IS HIGHER
WHEN WE CONDUCT THE TESTING
THROUGH THE QC TOLD TO VALIDATE
ACTUAL VERSUS RECORDED LEVELS
OF SPEED. WE ALSO MANAGED TO
CONNECT ABOUT COALITION FOR
DIGITAL INCLUSION IN OUR REGION
SO WE SEE THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE- ALL ASPECTS OF THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. INCLUDING
CRACKS OPEN ADOPTION AND
CONNECTEDTO A PORTABLE
CONNECTIVITY. THE FUNDING GAP
IN OUR REGION IS HUGE IT WOULD
COST ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONNECT ALL
OF OUR OWN CHURCH HELPFUL FIBER
NOT TO MENTION THE THOUSANDS OF
UNDERSERVED HOUSEHOLDS INNER
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
URBAN NEIGHBORHOODS. THE
CAPTAINS FINE CALIFORNIA BANNED
SERVICES FUND ADMINISTERED BY
THE PCS CURRENTLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED DEMONSTRATING
THE HIGH DEMAND FOR THESE FUNDS
WE CANNOT REACH OUR
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED 98%
TARGET. WITHOUT CONTINUED CAST
THE FUNDING. FORTY TWO FORTY
BECAUSE WILL PUT COULD BE.
INVEST IN THE NEED IN. AN EX
FUNDING ELIGIBILITY FOR LOCAL
AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS ENABLING
NEW SOLUTIONS WHERE WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GET INVESTED I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WITH THE
GOVERNOR TRANSFORMATIVE
INVESTMENT OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE
MILE NETWORK WE STILL NEED. TO
GET TO THE LAST MILE AND THAT'S
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCE
SERVICES FUND ENABLES US TO DO
AND THEN THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
TIME IN OUR FUNDING FROM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY WE'RE GONNA
GO TO SPEAKERS HERE IN THE
GALLERY ON SUPPORT- LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE ONE ALL SET. YES THANK
YOU MR CHAIR MEMBERS OF BURNING
OROZCO WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE
INDUSTRY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AMANDA THANK YOU. THANKS VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY
AND- WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WE'RE GONNA GO TO ROOM
TWELVE THERE ARE NO SPEAKERS
OUT THERE THAT HAVE. SHOWN
THEMSELVESSO WILL COME TO THE
PHONE LINES AND TO ASK FOR
PEACE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. FOR
SPEAKERS ON THIS PHONE LINES
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION. IF
ANY- MODERATOR P. PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FOURTEEN. LINE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NICOLE
BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT. NEXT PICKER. NINE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY MEMBERS
CARA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. NINE FORTY
FOUR. MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
NINE FORTY EIGHT. FOR INSTANCE
ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE BE AMERICA
AS WELL AS- CHIN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. NINE
FORTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KEPT DEAL WITH.
TWENTY EIGHT THE COUNTY'S
OAKLAND PORT. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. NINE FORTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON VERONICA AVAILABLE
FOR USE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD ACTION FUND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. BLIND. FIFTY ALL
THE DATA WHILE CALIFORNIA IN
FAVOR OF RECOVERING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. THAT HAVE BEEN STOLEN
BY THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY TO
BROADER CHANGE TO THE PREMISES
AND WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
GO TO THE NEXT. IN SUPPORT JUST
TAKE YOUR NAME YOUR PET'S AND
ANY AFFILIATE. NINE FORTY FIVE.
NINE FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT PICKER. LINE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KIRK BLACKBURN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS THAT
ACT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT SPEAKER. FORTY
SIX. STORY LINE SHARE OF THE
CDP WORLD CAUCUS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT BECAUSE. LINE. FOURTEEN
GOOD AFTERNOON TYLER MONDAY ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES
CALIFORNIA EXPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE
SIXTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBER DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK WITH THE SUPPORT
CEMENTED POSITION ON THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. FINE. THIRTY NINE.
JONATHAN HOWARD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMAN AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE. FIFTY
FIVE. MEMBERS OF THE US SO WE
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
CLIENTS AND SUPPORT THAT. HI
MONICA THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY AND
USE THAT TO LARRY VIEW. AT NAPA
AND WITH THAT THE PORT IF
AMENDED PETITION FOR THE EFFORT
REALLY FELT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER. MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE ELSE HAS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK OKAY WE'LL MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION THERE IS NO
ORGANIZED OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL- WILL GO TO- ROOM ONE
TWELVE NOBODY IS PRESENT THERE
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE GALLERY. NO OPPOSITION
THE GALLERY WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AND TAKE UP. PUBLIC
COMMENTS. ABOUT THE STATE YOUR
POSITION YOUR NAME YOUR- YEAH
AND ANY AFFILIATION IF THERE IS
ANY- MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE.
Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF AP
FOURTEEN. IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR NO ONE HAD QUEUED UP.
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
HERE. IF THERE ARE ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE CENTER
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER CONTINUED WORK IN
BROADBAND- OF COURSE ADVOCATING
FOR ALL OF THE STATE BUT
PARTICULARLY FOR COMMUNITIES IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA AND I MYSELF
CARRYING THE BILL- AND I IN THE
SENATE- IT IS SO VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE GET THESE TWO BILLS
MOVING FORWARD WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED
BY WE KEEP SAYING THIS BIKE.
BYCHKOVA NINETEEN IT'S BEEN
VERY VERY CLEAR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS THE
BIPARTISAN EFFORT TO INCREASE
SPEEDS AND TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
PART OF THE UNITED STATES IS-
IS COVERED I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR HIS CONTINUED
WORK HE'S BEEN LIKE A MENTOR TO
ME FOR THEM THE BROADBAND SPACE
IN HIS COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS AS
WELL FOR THEIR CONTINUED WORK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BUT WILL
GO TO THE VICE CHAIRMAN SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO DISPERSE SAY
THAT- TO THE AUTHOR AND BOTH
AUTHORS ACTUALLY. THAT- I KNOW
YOUR HEART I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
WORKING REALLY HARD TO TRY TO
GET SOMETHING THAT. THE SILLY
RUMOR I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
SHE'S BEEN WORKING A DECADE I
ONLY BEEN HERE NINE YEARS. AND
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS AS
WELL SO I WANTED JUST. A MINUTE
I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY AND I WANT TO LAY
OUT SOME REASONS WHY. I DON'T
BELIEVE. WE'RE GOING TO GET.
WHERE WE WANT TO GO. IN I KNOW
THAT WHEN THE SENATOR HAD HER
BILL UP I TALKED ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE. SAME SAME REASONS FIRST
OFF I WANT TO SHARE. THAT
ADDING MONEY TO THE POT ISN'T
ALWAYS GONNA SOLVE THE PROBLEM
AND I KNOW THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO PUT A LOT OF RESOURCES
IN BUT WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO
DO IS WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT.
CALIFORNIA IS A MAP OF WHO'S
BEING SERED BY PRIVATE
COMPANIES AND WHO'S NOT BEING
SERVED AND I KNOW THAT THE
SENATOR COPULAR OWES BILL. WE
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THAT IN
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
HAVE ARE THAT. THE PRIVATE SIDE
OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE GONNA SUPPORT
OF AMENDED. BUT IN THE TIME
I'VE BEEN HERE ONLY ONE COMPANY.
HAS USED THE CAST OF FUNDS TO
ACTUALLY EXTEND OUT. AND THAT
WAS ONLY BECAUSE THEY WERE
FORCED TO IN AN ACQUISITION TO
SUPPLY SERVICES. SO WHAT WE
HAVE IS WE HAVE A CAR IN
CALIFORNIA IS BROADBAND WITH NO
WHEELS ON IT WE CAN'T GET WHERE
WE WANT TO GO. BUT WE CONTINUE
TO PUT GAS IN IT AND ADD MORE
GAS BUT IT'S NOT MOVING. WE
HAVE SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. IN
THE- BUDGET POTENTIAL SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IT'S GOING TO
BE SUPPOSE THE USED.FOR THE
MIDDLE MILE. SO THAT'S LIKE A
FREEWAY WITH BILL ON RAMPS OR
OFF RAMPS WE CAN'T GET WHERE WE
WANT TO GO. SO FOR ME THE
FRUSTRATION IS THAT WE NEED TO
SIT DOWN AND WE NEED TO SAY TO
THAT WHERE DO WE HAVE PLACES
THAT WE DON'T. HAVE SERVICE AND
I HAVE A LOT OF THOSE PLACES.
AND WE NEED TO SAY TO THE
PRIVATE UTILITY. YOU'RE GOING
TO HELP US GET WHERE WE WANT TO
GO IN THIS CASE THEY WON'T TAKE
THE CAST OF FUNDS. THEY DON'T
USE. AND THE HISTORY WILL SHOW
US THAT WE'RE GONNA SPEND THE
MONEY AGAIN. AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET. WHERE WE WANT TO
GO. INTEL WE PUT THE UTILITIES.
THAT'S COMCAST EIGHTEEN T.
VERIZON ALL THOSE PEOPLE ALONG
WITH THE REGULATOR WHICH IS THE
P. U. C. PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. AND THE LEGISLATOR
IN A ROOM AND FIGURE OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY DELIVER
THE SERVICES IN A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE DOING THE SAME
THING THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR
THE LAST NINE YEARS WHICH IS
PUTTING MONEY IN THE SYSTEM.
AND NOT GETTING DELIVERABLES
OUT THE OTHER END SO THIS IS
THE THIS IS TO THE POOR BILLS
NOW PUT TOGETHER. THERE WAS. A
TWO OTHER BUILDERS ANOTHER BILL
COMING UP TODAY ON BROAD BANDS
WE'VE GOT FOUR BILLS. TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO RATHER SIMPLY
TWO OUT OF THE SENATE I WILL
NOT BE SUPPORTING ANY OF THEM
WE'RE GONNA BE UNTIL WE SIT
DOWN AND ACTUALLY DO THE RIGHT
THING WHICH IS. GET GOOD POLICY
AND BASICALLY GET THE UTILITIES
TO DO WHAT THEY SHOULD DO. NOW
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WHICH YOU'VE ALL HEARD
THAT. THEY'RE C. TO EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY HAS A- GIANT SIX LANE
FREEWAY GOING RIGHT UP MY
DISTRICT. OF BROADBAND AND I
CANNOT TAP INTO IT BECAUSE THEY
CHOOSE NOT TO. BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T MAKE ENOUGH MONEY THERE.
THESE CASTS OF FUNDS COULD HELP.
PUT THE MONEY IN THE POT. TO
GET THAT GET THAT SERVICES TO
MY SCHOOLS TO MY TO MY
LIBRARIES TO OUR BUSINESSES.
BUT THEY CHOOSE NOT TO USE IT
AND THAT GOES FOR ALL THE TEAMS
I'M NOT JUST PICKING ON ONE
THEY ALL DO IT BECAUSE THEIR-
PROFIT CENTERS. THIS BILLS THIS
MONEY SHOULD BE HELPING US GET
THERE BUT IF THEY NEVER TAP
INTO IT WE WON'T GET THERE.
SOMEHOW WE HAVE TO FORCE THEM
TO BE AT THE TABLE THE SAYS.
WE'RE GOING TO GET THE SERVICES
WITHOUT HAVING TO BUILD. A
COMPLETE NEW NETWORK. AROUND
THEM TO GET THERE THE CALL
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH MONEY. IN
THE STATE TO EVER GET THERE SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I WANT TO SAY
AGAIN I RESPECT BOTH THE
AUTHORS. I KNOW THEIR HEART I
KNOW THEY'RE TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. BUT THIS ISN'T
GONNA GET WHAT WE WANT. IN MY
OPINION. THANK YOU MR CHAIR OUR
BOARD JUST. SURE I'D LIKE TO I
COMMEND THE AUTHORS OFFER THE
WORK THEY'RE DOING IN THE
SPACE- I'VE DONE MY BEST TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH
THE ABSENCE OF BROADBAND IN- MY
DISTRICT REPRESENTING ALL OR
PARTS OF ELEVEN COUNTIES
NATIONALLY I'M GONNA HAVE A LOT
OF RURAL FOOTHILL AND MOUNTAIN
COMMUNITIES- THAT DO NOT HAVE
SERVICE. I THINK WHAT I'VE
LEARNED DURING THE PANDEMIC IS
THAT AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT.
WHAT WE DEEM TO BE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS
SUPPLY CHAIN FOOD WATER. AND
OTHER TYPES OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE PANDEMIC TAUGHT US THAT
BROADBAND SHOULD NOW BE
CONSIDERED. PART OF OUR CENTRAL
PORTFOLIO. IT IF THAT IS THE
CASE AS CALIFORNIA DEEMS IT TO
BE. WITH OUR SURPLUS OF LET'S
SAY SEVENTY FIVE AND IT'S A BIT
OF A MOVING TARGET STILL. THAT
WE SHOULD BE MAKING MORE STATE
INVESTMENT INTO THIS NINE OH
SEVEN BILLION IS NOTHING TO
SNEEZE AT. IF THAT'S THE NUMBER
THAT IS MOVING FORWARD RIGHT
NOW. HI I APPLAUD THE
INVESTMENT IN THE MIDDLE MILE
IN OTHER IN- IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS BUT
THAT FINAL MILE. NEEDS TO BE
PART OF THE EQUATION.
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE THESE
RURAL AREAS I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR REPRESENTS A NUMBER OF
THEM HERSELF- I DON'T BELIEVE
WE NEED TO HAVE A SURCHARGE TO
BE ABLE TO PUT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS FORWARD THERE SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD BE USING
GENERAL FUND MONEY TO MAKE THIS
INVESTMENT NOW THERE'S A COUPLE
OF VARIATIONS THAT COULD TAKE
PLACE WITH A SURCHARGE WHETHER
IT BE A STATE GUARANTEE OR THE
SURCHARGE IS SATISFIED BY THE
STATE COMMITMENTS- IN MAYBE
DOWN THE ROAD MAINTENANCE COULD
BE- BORNE BY THOSE ACCOUNT
HOLDERS. BUT I THINK THIS IS A
STRONG STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT THE FUNDING
MECHANISM I THINK IS MISPLACED
GIVEN HOW WE HAVE STATED BOTH
AT THE EXECUTIVE LEVEL AS WELL
AS LEGISLATIVE LEVEL THAT IF
THIS IS WHAT WE BELIEVE TO BE
THE CENTRAL SERVICE WE NEED TO
PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH
IS THE ONLY WAY TO DO THAT IS A
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT AND I
KNOW THERE ARE POLITICAL
CURRENTS AND CROSS CURRENTS
THAT MAY- DISCOURAGE THAT TYPE
OF SIGNIFICANT CAPITAL
INVESTMENT BUT THAT WOULD BE
THE RIGHT THING TO DO. VERY
WELL- I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT WE DO HAVE- GOING EXCEPT
CENTER GONZALEZ MOTION NOW ON
THE BILL THAT INCLUDES
AMENDMENTS AND I BELIEVE THAT
IN THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
MINISTER FOR CEMENT AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENT GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. WILL BE SEEN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE AND IN THE INTERIM I
KNOW- THE AUTHORS EXPRESSED
INTEREST TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE AS
WE KNOW WE ARE WORKING ON NOT
ONLY SEVERAL BILLS BUT SOME
BUDGET ITEMS THAT MAY PERTAIN
TO THIS SO HOW WE STRUCTURE
THESE INVESTMENTS MAY INCLUDE
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
SHARED TODAY. IN TERMS OF THAT
IN SOME STATE FUNDS INTO THIS
INITIATIVE AND I THINK
GENERALLY THEY SHOULD COVER THE
CONNECTIONS FROM THE MIDDLE
MILE TO OUR INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES AND THIS FUND
COURSE I BELIEVE REALLY NEEDS A
GIRL THAT THE MONEY HAS BEEN
UTILIZED SUCCESSFULLY PASS AND
ALL WE CAN DO IT ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE HAVE A STRATEGY AND
WE'RE WORKING ON IMPROVING ON
THAT STRATEGY AS WE SPEAK. SO I
WANT TO ASK THE- AUTHOR TO MAKE
SOME CLOSING REMARKS FOR YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE IF NOT WE HAVE RAGE ABOUT WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR I
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND I DO
WANT TO CLARIFICATIONS FOR
SENATOR DOLLY. AT FOURTEEN
EXPANDS WHO CAN USE CAN THE
CASTLE TO MAKE IT MORE
ACCESSIBLE I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT AT THE FIRST TIME WE DID
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE THERE WERE
SOME BUMPS IN THE ROAD YOU KNOW
IF WE COULD DO PERFECT-
LEGISLATION EVERY SINGLE TIME I
STOOD UP HERE THAT THE ONE
THING BUT ONE OF MY GOALS IS TO
MAKE SURE WE DO A VERY GOOD-
FRAMEWORK AND. THE SENATOR AND
I HAVE WORKED. FOR HOURS AND
DAYS AND HALF STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED IS TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAD A GOOD FRAMEWORK TO
GO AHEAD. YOU KNOW I WANT TO
JUST REMIND YOU THAT DOES
BENEFIT THE RURAL AREAS. YOU
KNOW IF YOU KNOW WHERE I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE SATISFY
THOUGH BUT ALSO AS SENATOR
GONZALES WILL TELL YOU. THAT
HER URBAN AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE
CONNECTIVITY. THE BILL PER
PRIORITIZES RURAL AREAS. OFF
THE TERROR ONLY AT TEN ONE
SERVICE THAT PROVIDES BROADBAND
AND AREAS I. S. P.'S- TYPICALLY
SERVE. MONEY FOR THEM WITH
LITTLE RETURN. IN THE BILL
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS GPAS TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS COOPS CAN ACCESS
THE CAPS OF FUNDS TO BUILD
BROADBAND I'M MAKING THIS LOCAL
REGIONAL APPROACH AS YOU KNOW
IN YOUR DISCIPLINE THIS HAS ONE
OF THE BEST SYSTEMS AND I
REALLY THINK THAT WE SHOULD
MIRROR WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN AND
HOW THEY'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND
WE WANT THEM TO CONTINUE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. END USERS WILL FIND
THE SURCHARGE RATE. TO DIG DEEP
FREEZE. SO I DON'T WANT YOU TO
THINK THAT THIS IS LIKE THE END
OF THE WORLD IS THE MAX WE CAN
COLLECT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. IT WILL
BE USE VERY- STRATEGICALLY- IF
YOU HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR'S
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR BROADBAND. I
WOULD THINK- I THINK MY VEHICLE.
AUTHOR MRS- GETS ALL THIS AND I
CAN AGREE THAT A LOT OF THE
STUFF IS IN THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN
IS A LOT OF THE STUFF THAT'S IN
OUR BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
FORWARD ON THAT AND WE HAVE
SUGGESTIONS EVEN MAKE THAT
BETTER. SO I CAN I KNOW YOUR
CONCERN I KNOW THAT- WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE MAKE A
POINT. ABOUT THE FACT THE
MATTER IS THAT WE CANNOT GO ON.
ANY LONGER WITHOUT HAVING
CONNECT CONNECTIVITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR I WILL.
VERY WELL THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AP FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUILAR CURRY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST THE MEN'S AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. WESSEL
HI WESSEL HI DOLLY. TALLY KNOWN
BETTER BY BECKER HI. FORTUS
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT BRADFORD HI
DOT. THE FIRM HI. FIGMENT HI
AIKMAN HI CONTROLLERS HI CONSOL
IS FINE GROSS. HERTZBERG
REQUIRE. MAN WELL I MAN HI
RUBIO. RUBIO HI STERN HI STERN
I IT. IT'S WEDNESDAY IT'S
BETTER THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OF THE PROPS OF MEMBERS
THANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MEMBERS
A TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR VOTES
EXCELLENT WORK WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO FOLLOW THE NUMBER TWO A.
B. FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WOOD RELATED TO BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
GENERATE SO WHEN MEMBERS THIS
COMMITTEE IS WELL AWARE OF THE
MYRIAD OF WAYS IN WHICH THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AS MANIFESTED
ITSELF THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
THIS PAST YEAR. WHETHER IT IS
EDUCATION THE DIGITAL
MARKETPLACE HEALTH CARE OR
ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT SERVICES.
THE GATEWAY TO FUNDAMENTAL
RESOURCES IS INCREASINGLY
ONLINE. THE PROPOSALS I PUT
FORTH IN AB FORTY ONE OUR
BASELINE STEPS WE MUST TAKE TO
BRING ALIFORNIA'S DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. IT'S TAKING
OFFICE COMMON SENSE EXPANSION
OF BROADBAND ACCESS HAS BEEN A
PRIORITY OF MINE. I'M EXCITED
TO BE ABLE TO BRING THAT
WORKING KNOWLEDGE TO THE TABLE
AS WE COLLABORATE BY CAMERON
LEE AND WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
THE CONCEPT OF DIG ONCE IS NOT
A NEW POLICY AREA FOR ME I'M
BRINGING THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE
MY COLLEAGUES AGAIN. BECAUSE%
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF OUR STATE
AGENCIES DO NOT RECOGNIZE THE
URGENCY WITH WHICH WE MUST ROLL
OUT BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE.
AS SIMPLY AS WE UPGRADE OUR
STATE ROADWAYS WE NEED TO
DETERMINE HOW. NOT IF BROADBAND
IS A PART OF THAT IMMINENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT. I
CAN'T THINK OF A BETTER WAY
THAN TO LAY CONDUIT- WHEN WE
HAVE THE GROUND ALREADY OPENED
UP. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SPENDING OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN MIDDLE MILE DEPLOYMENT WHICH
IS EXCITING. BUT THEN WE HAVE A
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAXIMIZE COST SAVINGS
OPPORTUNITIES IS IT TOO MUCH TO
ASK IF WE GET BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT. YEAH
AND PLANNED ROAD INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES IN SYNC. I'M ASKING
FOR SOME SIMPLE PLANNING BY OUR
STATE AGENCIES WHICH CAN REDUCE
THE COST OF DEPLOYMENT BY UP
290% ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION.
SIMILARLY I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THAT OUR CURRENT BROADBAND
SERVICE MAPS ARE WOEFULLY
LACKING IN DETAIL. THEY LEAVE
PEOPLE DISCONNECTED AND
FRUSTRATED BY CRUDELY MARKING
BASS CENSUS BLOCKS SERVED. AND
UNSERVED SOMETIMES BASED ON A
SINGLE HOUSEHOLD. I GREW
INCREASINGLY FRUSTRATED AS WE
CONTINUE DISCUSSING ACCESS TO
STATE GRANTS AND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT BASED
ON MAPS THAT ARE FLAT WRONG.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEIGHBORHOOD
GROUPS COOPERATIVES AND MANY
OTHERS ARE EAGER TO GET ONLINE.
THE LEAST WE CAN DO IS TO GIVE
THEM AN ACCURATE MAP. THAT
ACTUALLY CAPTURES THE PROBLEM
IN THEIR COMMUNITY THEY ARE
WORKING TO SOLVE. I'M CONFIDENT
THE C. P. C. C. P. U. C. HAS
THE DATA WE SIMPLY NEED TO
PRESENT. IT IN A WAY THAT GIVES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE POWER TO
USE IT EFFECTIVELY LIKE MANY
OTHER STATES HAVE ALREADY DONE.
WE WORKED WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS THAT I
BELIEVE REFINE AND PRESERVE THE
SPIRIT OF THIS BILL. I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THEIR TIME. AND
THEY DO ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS.
YOUR EXPERTISE IN THIS ISSUE. I
KNOW THEY ARE HIS PASSIONS I AM
ABOUT GETTING CALIFORNIA'S
ONLINE. MULTI MILLIONAIRE
PROPOSAL SIMPLE FIRST LET'S
BETTER UNDERSTAND OUR CURRENT
BROADBAND NEEDS AND LET'S USE A
LITTLE FORESIGHT. WHEN CALTRANS
BREAKS GROUND. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. ABOUT. WELL WE
HAVE TWO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
SO- NO ACTUALLY I'M SORRY ONE
SPEAKER IN SUPPORT WHEN IN
OPPOSITION. EACH SPEAKER GETS
THREE MINUTES FOR THE
PRESENTATION DO WE HAVE ANY
SPEAKERS ON IN SUPPORT. NO OKAY
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT MY BAD-
WILL GO TO- SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ANYBODY
HERE IN I'M SORRY- S. SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF WE
HAVE ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. FORTY ONE AND
THE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. DO WE
HAVE ANY SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE NOTHING ONE
TWELVE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. MODERATORPLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FORTY ONE. AND SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NINE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOR
INSTANCE ON BEHALF OF THE OCEAN
IN SUPPORT. NEXT BECAUSE. NINE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ERICA HOPPING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. NEXT
PICKER FLYING FIFTY NINE.
PRODUCT AVAILABLE CREDIT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
ACTION IN SUPPORT. NEXT BIG
GROUP. LINE SIXTY ONE.
CATHERINE DUNN YOU WANT TO
NURSES FOR HEALTHY AND BERMAN
IN SUPPORT. NEXT PICKER. THE
LINE. SIXTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS BILLY MCKAY CALLING ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
INSPIRED DESIGN THANK YOU. THE
NEXT BIGGER. LINE SIXTEEN.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
CALLING THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK WITH THE SUPPORT OF
FERMENTED POSITION. NEXT BIGGER.
LINE. FORTY SIX. NINE FOUR SIX
YOUR OPEN. ALL RIGHT TO REMIND
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
RURAL CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NEXT BAKER. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE ELSETHANK YOU AT THE
TIME THIS TIME OKAY VERY WELL
WE'LL GO TO OUR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE SPEAKER
THAT HAS AN ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION OPPOSITION
JONATHAN ADAM BELL IS WITH THE-
THIRD HOUSE LLC IS ON THE PHONE.
RICHARD KERR- THANK YOU MR
MEMBERS STARTED THEIR BILL-
HERE ON BEHALF OF TI EIGHTY
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY. AND I'M
WONDERING IF YOU HAVE BEEN
OPPOSED I'M SORRY I JUST WANNA
REMIND YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES.
START OKAY NO PROBLEM- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE BEEN UP CLOSE WE'RE
STILL REVIEWING THE INTERNAL
FEEDBACK ON THE PROPOSED
COMMITMENTS IN THE NOW OF THE-
WE BELIEVE. CONTINUE REVIEWING
THE ACTUAL LANGUAGES BEING
PROPOSED THAT THESE MAY ADDRESS
THE REMAINING CONCERNS ON THE
BILL SO WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ALONG WITH THE AUTHOR YOU
KNOW AND HIS STAFF FOR THE
AMOUNT OF WORK THAT IS- GONE
INTO THIS BILL. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING. THE NEW
AMENDED LANGUAGE. THANK YOU.
YOU WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN UP
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY HERE IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY NO ONE IS IN A
POSITION OF. AB FORTY ONE WILL
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. NOBODY'S
OPPOSITION ROOM ONE TWELVE TO
GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATORS CAN YOU. MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. FORTY ONE.
IF AN OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY
ONE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO. HEY
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE HAD QUEUED
UP. WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE
NOW- WE HAVE- CENTER EIGHT MEN
THAT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR- I WOULD LIKE THAT
JUST TO. MOVE THIS BILL WHEN
THE TIME IS RIGHT AND THIS
SEEMS LIKE YOU KNOW IN IN- IN
CARPENTRY IN AND SHOWING YOU DO
THE SAME THING YOU MEASURE
TWICE CUT ONCE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS THE BILL
EVEN MY GOOD FRIEND FROM BEAVER
COULD GET BEHIND. AND I'VE
MOVED TO. MOVE THIS BILL.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I ALSO THINK THIS IS A-
A GOOD BILL BUT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND A PORTION OF IT- IN
PARTICULAR IF I MAY ASK THE
AUTHOR. ACCORDING TO THE BILL
IS SAYS IT WILL ALLOW MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO SUBMIT A
REQUEST FOR BETTER INTERNET%
SERVICE AND COLLECT. THE
DESIRED- INTERNET SPEED IS OUR
MONTHLY INTERNET CASAL. CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON THAT IN TERMS OF
IF THIS JUST FOR. DATA
COLLECTION OR ARE THESE.
REQUESTS GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED AND IF SO HOW ARE
ARE YOU GOING TO PRIORITIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR- I
THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS CREATE A SITUATION WHERE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO ACCESS
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT SERVICES
ARE AVAILABLE WHAT WHAT IS
AROUND THEM HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DO THAT CURRENTLY IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT THE MAPS ARE NOW
INACCURATE. AS I SAID IN MY
STATEMENT- YOU COULD ACTUALLY
HAVE A ONE PERSON HAVING
SERVICE IN A CENSUS BLOCK AND
THAT WOULD- THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD SHOW THAT THAT AREA IS
SERVED AND THAT'S REALLY NOT
SERVED QUITE FRANKLY IN MY
OPINION. SO WE'RE RYING TO
CREATE A SYSTEM WHERE-
INTERESTED PARTIES THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR A WAY TO BUILD OUT
INTERNET ACCESS CAN GET THE
DATA THEY NEED. TO SEE WHAT'S
ACTUALLY THERE- AND WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES MIGHT BE TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE CURRENT
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU THEY
CANNOT TIME. DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
OKAY I DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE-
WE HAVE A MOTION-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS I THINK FUNDAMENTAL TO
THIS IS THAT AND I AND I THINK
SUSAN AS AS SENATOR ECHOING
SKEWS ME- FOR HER COMMENTS I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU
ABSOLUTELY MEASURE MEASURE
TWICE AND CUT ONCE. WE NEED TO
KNOW WHERE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY ACCESS IT
AND USE IT IN THE MOST
APPROPRIATE MANNER- AND WHEN WE
ARE ACTUALLY BUILDING THINGS-
IT WOULDN'T IT BE NICE IF WE
COULD ACTUALLY- UTILIZE THE
OPEN INFRASTRUCTURE- AS IS
BEING CONSTRUCTED TO ACTUALLY
MOVE THESE PROJECTS FORWARD-
AND- WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE MOTION IS TO PASS IN ROOF
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION. SEGMENT OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHTY EIGHT SIX EIGHTY FORTY
ONE BY PHONE NUMBER WOULD IT
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
WITH A COMMITMENT TO AMEND IN
TRANSPORTATION. WESSEL ESSELS
HI DOLLY BY. KELLY HI BECKER.
BECKER HI FORTUS. BRADFORD R.
BRADFORD I DON. HI GOD HI
AIKMAN. HEY KEVIN HI FRIENDS
ALL THIS HI. AND SOLACE BY.
GROW. HERTZBERG THE- HERTZBERG
HI REQUIRE THAT THE WOUNDED MAN
HI MAN HI RUBIO HI RUBIO BY
STERN ALL RIGHT CERN HI. ELEVEN
A STRIP THAT'S ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUTPUT WILL LOOK AT THE
ROLE OF TRAPS MEMBERS WILL GO
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B.
THREE TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS SIR BILL
RELATED. TO BIOMASS WELCOME SIR
A SIMILAR NUMBER CELLS BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
SENATOR MEMBERS- PLEASE
APOLOGIZE USE OF SUNGLASSES OF
THEY ARE MEDICALLY NECESSARY
THIS WEEK. BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE TWENTY TWO WHICH
WILL CORRECT CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER
PRIORITIZING. FUNDING FOR NEW
INNOVATIVE BIOMASS PROJECTS
THROUGH THE EPIC PROGRAM.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF FORESTRY MORE EPIC
FUNDING IS NEEDED FOR BIOMASS
PROJECTS TO REDUCE OPEN BURNING
OF AGRICULTURAL WASTE. MITIGATE
WILDFIRE RISKS AND CREATE CLEAN
ENERGY TO STABILIZE OUR GRIDS
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY TWO WILL
HELP REDUCE WASTE AND MEET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS BY INVESTING IN
THE NEXT GENERATION OF BIOMASS.
PROJECTS WHICH WILL PRODUCE
RENEWABLE ENERGY OUT OF WASTE
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE PUT IN
A LANDFILL OR BURNED. AT
MEMBERS JUST QUITE FRANKLY.
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
WE'RE TRYING TO PUSH THE
BIOMASS FACILITIES BECAUSE IF
YOU DRIVE THROUGH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OR- EVEN A LOT OF PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA WHAT YOU'LL FIND
IS A LOT OF WAYS IS ACTUALLY
PUT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE FIELD.
AND LIT ON FIRE AND I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY THE WORST THING
YOU CAN DO IN TERMS OF
PARTICULATE MATTER GOING INTO
THE AIR. IT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOW. THIS IS A MECHANISM THAT
ALLOWS FOR SOME OF THAT TO BE
CAPTURED. AND RISK FREE
RENEWABLE ENERGY OUT OF IT.
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY TWO IS
SUPPORTED BY A WIDE COALITION
OF AIR DISTRICTS. WATER AND
WASTEWATER AGENCIES THIRTY
SEVERAL COUNTIES RENEWABLE
ENERGY STAKEHOLDERS. AND CLEAN
ENERGY GROUPS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- WITH LEADERS TESTIFIED
BY PHONE SUPPORT IS. JULIA
LEVIN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND MISS CHRISTINA
DARLINGTON FROM THE PLASTER
COUNTY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT. VERY WELL IF THEY'RE
ON THE PHONE WE HAVE THREE
MINUTES SET ASIDE FOR BOTH
SPEAKERS FOR EACH SPEAKER GETS.
A MINUTE AND A HALF WILL BEGIN
WITH JULIA LEVIN. WHAT ABOUT
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. GOOD AFTERNOON
JULIANNA SEVEN WITH A BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. A.
B. THREE TWO TWO WILL PROVIDE
MANY BENEFITS TO RATEPAYERS THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE CLIMATE.
CALIFORNIA GENERATES MILLIONS
OF TONS OF BIOMASS WASTE
ANNUALLY INCLUDING FOREST WASTE
THAT MUST BE REMOVED PURSUANT
TO SB NINE OH ONE- CULTURAL
WASTE AND URBAN WOOD WASTE.
MOST OF THIS WASTE EITHER SENT
TO LANDFILLS CAN PILE TO DECAY
OR OPEN BURNED. ALL OF WHICH
WERE THESE POWERFUL SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANT. AND OF
BURNING OR LANDFILLING IS WASTE
CAN BE CONVERTED TO FIRM
RENEWABLE POWER THAT'S
AVAILABLE IN SOLAR AND WIND OR
NOT. EIGHTY THREE TO ASK THE
CDC TO CONSIDER USING EPIC
FUNDING TO DEMONSTRATE NEW AND
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES TO
CONVERT BIOMASS WASTE TO
ELECTRICITY. FUNDING CANNOT BE
USED TO SUBSIDIZE EXISTING
FACILITIES OLD TECHNOLOGIES.
STATE AGENCIES ARE DEPENDING ON
BIOMASS TO MEET A WIDE RANGE OF
OBJECTIVES THE AIRPORT IS
CALLED FOR INCREASED FUNDING
FOR BIOENERGY TO REDUCE OPEN
BURNING OF WASTE THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY IS CULTURE ETHICS
FUNDING TO CONVERT FOREST
BIOMASS TO ENERGY. RECYCLED
WASTE DIVERSION REGULATIONS
ONLY ALLOW TWO ALTERNATIVES TO
LANDFILLING CONVERTING BIOMASS
TO ELECTRICITY OR TO MULCH AND
CPC A CALL FOR MORE FROM POWER
FROM RENEWABLE RESOURCES EIGHTY
THREE TO HELP CALIFORNIA DEAL
WITH MILLIONS OF TONS OF WASTE
ANNUALLY AND INCREASE THE
PRODUCTION OF PHARMACEUTICAL
POWER WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
PASS EIGHTY THREE TO TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE
TO- CHRISTINA DARLINGTON THE.
PLASTER COUNTY- POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT. HI THIS IS
CHRISTINA ARLINGTON AND
TESTIFYING ON TWITTER TO OUR
DISTRICT ACTION NORTHERN SONOMA
COUNTY AND THE COUNTY ARE
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT.
BOTH OF WHICH SUPPORT THIS
BILL. AT TWO AM DECIDE WHAT
JULIA HAD MENTIONED IN THE
PREVIOUS MOMENTS. WE SEE THAT
BIOMASS ENERGY CAN REALLY HELP
OUR AIR QUALITY. FOR EXAMPLE
PLASTER COUNTY WE DID A STUDY
JUST OUT IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
THAT RECOGNIZES THAT USING
BIOMASS. FOR ELECTRICITY
ACTUALLY REDUCES BLACK CARBON
AND PARTICULAR MATTER WHAT
YOU'RE WANTING TO CHANGE MY
NINETY EIGHT PERCENT. METHANE
AND VOCS ARE REDUCED BY NINETY
FIVE PERCENT. KNOX AND SMOG
FORMING POLLUTANTS REDUCE BY
OVER FORTY PERCENT. AND THESE
ARE NUMBERS THAT ARE WELL
RELEVANT TO THE EXISTING
BIOMASS ELECTRICITY
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT THESE
NUMBERS YOU CAN EXPECT EVEN
FURTHER REDUCTIONS WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT A DANCE TECHNOLOGIES
AS WELL AS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS WHICH CAN BE
ACHIEVED THROUGH. SOME OF THE
MORE ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES. THE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS ALSO
RECOGNIZED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FOCUS ON THE PORT
THROUGH THE FOREST CARBON
PLANTS AND USING BIOMASS LATER
LIKE TRAGEDY AND FOR OTHER
PURPOSES. BUT THAT WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING WITH. THE WOOD
WASTE THAT'S COMING OUT OF OUR
FUEL REDUCTION FUEL LOAD
PRODUCT- PROJECT IF WE DO NOT
FIND A WAY TO USE THAT AND THE
PLACES WHERE WASTE USUALLY ENDS
UP IN A WILDFIRE. EXACERBATING
AN ALREADY CRITICAL ISSUE WE
HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO ON
ON BEHALF OF BOTH OF THE AIR
DISTRICT. WE- I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER VOTING YES. ON THIS
EIGHTY THREE TO TWO THANK YOU.
I THIRTY OF THAT VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. HOW WE'RE GONNA- WE
CURRENT INSURED SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. BUT A. B. THREE TWENTY
TWO WILL COME TO THE GALLERY
AND THE SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT IN
THE GALLERY WE HAVE. A SPEAKER
READY TO GO. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
AND MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES
IN SUPPORT OF MR SALLIS IS BILL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE SCHOOL
KILLING. ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
THE GALLERY ANYONE- WILL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE IF THERE'S
ANYONE AVAILABLE ROOM TWELVE NO
ONE IS- THEY'RE IN ROOM TWELVE.
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINERS
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. OF A. B.
THREE TWENTY TWO AM WE ASK THE
SPEAKER TO CONFINE THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME- THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND ANY
AFFILIATION IF. AND SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO
WELCOME TO A LINE OF SIX ZERO
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT BIGGER.
ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TEACHER MEMBERS REMAINS
TO BE SEEN WITH THE WHITE MAN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF BLUE ENERGY
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. MISTER CHAIRMAN NO ONE
ELSE HAVE QUEUED UP. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION AND APPEARS WE
HAVE ONE SPEAKER THAT HAS AN
ORGANIZED. OPPOSITION
PRESENTATION JAMIE CATS YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES. THIS JAMIE
CATS ON THE PHONE. YES THANK
YOU SO MUCH JAMIE **** WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. AFTER WE
WORK ALONGSIDE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE SEVENTEEN
EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY- MANY
OF WHOM ARE IMPACTED BY THE- BY
OPEN AGRICULTURAL BURNING OF
COURSE GREATLY CONCERNED ABOUT
HAVING. THE ADDRESSING THESE
CONCERNS AS WELL AS MEETING
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS UNFORTUNATELY ET
THREE TWENTY TWO FAILS TO
ADDRESS ADEQUATELY ADDRESS
EITHER OF THESE SCHOOLS. HE YOU
KNOW BIOMASS IS NOT A CLEAN
ENERGY TECHNOLOGY- GET AMID
CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS WELL IS
IT ADMITTING. PARABEN AND IT.
BUT WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
IS THAT IT YOU KNOW BIG BILL
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY TWO WOULD
COMMIT 20% OF EPIC'S FUNDING.
TOWARD THESE TECHNOLOGIES
RATHER THAN. INVESTING IN TRUE
RENEWABLE TECHNOLOGIES IN
ADDITION. ALTHOUGH BIOMASS
FACILITIES ARE MARGINALLY
BETTER THAN OPEN AGRICULTURAL
BURNING CALIFORNIA SHOULDN'T
SET INSTEAD INVEST IN NON
EMITTING NON COMBUSTION
SOLUTIONS. FOR AGRICULTURAL
WASTE RATHER THAN INCENTIVISING
PROGRAMS THAT CONTINUE TO AMEND
AND CLICK THE ERROR AND
COMMUTING TO WORK ALONG SIDE
FOR THOSE REASONS. ALL WE ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ON EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF A.
B. THREE TWENTY TWO DO WE HAVE
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERIES-
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THREE TWENTY TWO.
OKAY WE'LL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION NO ONE IS PRESENT
ROOM ONE TWELVE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS. IN
OPPOSITION FAB THIRTY THREE
TWENTY TWO. AN APPARITION OF A.
B. THREE TWO TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE END ZERO. ONE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE US SO
WE SHOT THEM ACTUALLY CALLING
IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT AND THE
QUALITY OF THE TEACHING. THANK
YOU- MODERATOR PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
THREE TWO TWO. MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE OUT BELT HAVE QUEUED UP.
OKAY VERY WELL WILL COME TO THE
FLOOR BEGINNING WITH THE CENTER
A COMMAND AND FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK THE AUTHOR DEPORT PROVE
IT TOUGH I COULD BE A CO AUTHOR
THIS IS JUST KIND OF BILL THAT
I THINK WE NEED TO BE.
INVESTING IN A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T LIKE TO ADMIT THAT WE AS
HUMANS MAKE TRASH IN OUR-
ENVIRONMENT AND ON OUR WAYS OF
LIVING HAVE HAVE PRODUCTS THAT
WE MAKE IT WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING WITH WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING WITH THEM THE EITHER
END UP IN LANDFILLS AND I CAN
CERTAINLY TELL YOU AS SOMEBODY
WHO LIVES IN THE VALLEY IF YOU
DRIVE DOWN THE VALLEY. ON A DAY
WHEN THEY'RE DOING OPEN BURNS
YOU CAN'T BREATHE YOU CAN'T SEE
AND IT'S ALL JUST SITTING THERE
HOVERING SUCH WHEN THE FOG
STARTS ROLLING IN AND IT FEELS
LIKE THERE'S A BIG COMPRESSION
KEEPING ALL THAT BAD AIR RIGHT
DOWN ON THIS. IS A SMART WAY TO
BE ABLE TO GET RID OF THE WAYS
THAT WE CREATE IN A LESSER
GONNA STOP EATING I WOULD
CONTINUE TO HAVE WASTE
ASSOCIATED WITH OUR AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTS JUST AS WE DO AS HUMAN
BEINGS. SO I WOULD I WOULD MOVE
THIS BILL I WOULD THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK ON THIS AND
I WOULD ASK. TO BE A CO AUTHOR.
FERRE DOLLAR. THE MATURE ALSO
LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR I JUST
WANT TO SAY TO THE OPPOSITION
WHO CALLED IN. THAT LOOK IT
ISN'T A 100% BUT IT'S 98% AND
I'D RATHER HAVE 98% THEN ZERO
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING FROM OPEN
BURNER OTHER AREAS SO. THIS IS
THE ONE AREA THAT I KNOW THE
AUTHOR HAS WORKED ON THIS WE
WORKED ON THESE TOGETHER WE HAD
A- A BILL TOGETHER A FEW YEARS
AGO TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. AND I COMMEND YOU FOR
COMING FOR WHETHER IT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IT'S NOT A
100% BUT I'LL TAKE WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA GIVE ME WHICH IS A LOT
BETTER THAN WHAT WE HAVE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR. OKAY VERY WELL
ANYONE ELSE THEN THERE ARE NO
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL SO THE
MOTION BE DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SIR BRADFORD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I TO
JUST WANT TO. ADD MY VOICE IN
SUPPORT THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE AND IT'S AMAZING THAT
YOU CAN GO TO EUROPE AND THEY
HAVE BIOMASS AND BIO WASTE
FACILITIES AND THERE IS CLEAN
AS ANYTHING THAT YOU COULD EVER
HOPE FOR BUT HERE IN AMERICA
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE CAN'T DO
IT AND AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON STATED AS LONG AS YOU
HAVE HUMAN BEINGS YOU WILL HAVE
WASTE AND THIS IS A RELIABLE
SOURCE IS DISPATCHABLE FAR MORE
RELIABLE THAN WIND AND SOLAR SO
I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE. OUR ON
THIS COMMON SENSE MEASURE. VERY
WELL- CENTER BECKER. VETERAN
SAID THAT TAB I DO HEAR THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS ARE JUST
ONE NOTE THIS BILL. I READ
DOESN'T SPECIFY IT BUT A
PARTICULAR AMOUNT OR PERCENT OF
EPIC FANTASY DOESN'T OBLIGATE
ANYTHING IT DOES MAKE IT
AVAILABLE. THROUGH THE CHAIR-
YEAH THE OPPOSITION WAS
ACTUALLY SPEAKING TO THE FIRST
VERSION OF THE BILL BEFORE IT
WAS AMENDED THAT HAD A
PERCENTAGE THAT WE REMOVED AS
AMENDMENTS. TO KIND OF SATISFY
EVERYONE'S CONCERNS AS IT WAS
MOVING THROUGH SO. THE
OPPOSITION. FOR THE PERCENTAGE
YOU ARE CORRECT WAS A PREVIOUS
VERSION AND NOT IN THIS VERSION.
GREAT JOB IT WANTS TO CLARIFY
THAT. AND AS SUCH I WILL BE IN
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU FOR
**** THAT. VERY WELL- DID YOU
WANNA MAKE SOME CLOSING
COMMENTS SEVEN MISTER CHAIRMAN
IF I CAN'T FIRST LET ME- I
THINK THE CENTERS FOR THE
COMMENTS AND I WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE YOU LISTED AS CO AUTHORS
APPRECIATE EACH OF YOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THIS I
THINK THIS IS A SMART SOLUTION
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I
THINK THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY YOU SEE THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
A NUMBER OF AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICTS A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS A NUMBER OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY GROUPS ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BECAUSE IT'S
COMMON SENSE IT MAKES SENSE.
FOR US TO MOVE TO MOVE FORWARD
I'D RATHER HAVE I THINK IT WAS-
SENATOR THAT SPOKE EARLIER FROM
BEAVERS SAID 90% INSTEAD OF 0%
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
NOW THE DISSERVICE TO
CALIFORNIANS TO JUST OPEN FIELD
BURN AND NOT CREATE RENEWABLE
ENERGY OUT OF OUR WASTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- VERY WELL- WE HAVE A MOTION
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EIGHTY THREE TWENTY TWO
BY SOME NUMBERS ON THIS THE
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL BY WESSEL HI DARLENE HI.
DOLLY HI BECKER. BECKER HI
FORTUS. BRADFORD I BRADFORD HI
DOT HI DIANE HI AIKMAN ALL
RIGHT. EIGHT MEN HI CONTROLLERS
HI THEMSELVES HI HELLO.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I REQUIRE.
MAN HI MAN HI RUBIO. RUBIO HI
STERN. TANESHA THE BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT THANK
YOU THE ROLE OF REPS MEMBERS
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR A. B. FIVE TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU- A BILL
HAVING TO DO WITH WIND
GENERATION WELCOME AND BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THE CENTERS. EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY FIVE WILL JUMP
START A NEW CLEAN ENERGY
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA BY
DIRECTING THE STATE TO PREPARE
A STRATEGIC PLAN TO HARNESS THE
POWER OF OFFSHORE WIND. AFTER
THIS PAST YEAR HEAT WAVES
WILDFIRES BLACKOUTS IN THE LOSS
OF OVER A MILLION JOBS.
CALIFORNIA HAS A ONCE IN A.
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY JUST
TWENTY TO THIRTY MILES OFF OUR
COAST. TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND PUT PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK. OUR STATE IS ACCESS TO
ONE OF THE WORLD'S GREATEST
UNTAPPED SOURCES OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY. OFFSHORE WIND WITH THE
POTENTIAL TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE MEEDER CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS AND PROVIDE GOOD PAYING
JOBS. IN EUROPE AND ASIA MANY
COUNTRIES ARE FAR AHEAD OF THE
UNITED STATES IN THIS AREA.
FORTUNATELY THE BINA
MINISTRATION HAS ANNOUNCED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
INVESTMENT IN OFFSHORE WIND.
WELL EAST COAST STATES
AUTHORITIES SAID TWENTY NINE
GIGAWATTS OF TARGETS IN THIS
ARENA. OUR STATE HAS
ESTABLISHED NINE. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
NOT LEFT BEHIND. THIS BILL
GIVES US THE CHANCE TO CATCH UP
PARTICULARLY WITH THE RECENT
ANNOUNCEMENT BY THE WHITE HOUSE
AND A GOVERNOR TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH LEASE AUCTIONS OFF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST. BUFFER WIND
CAN ENSURE A DIVERSE RELIABLE
PORTFOLIO OF CLEAN POWER.
COMPLEMENTING SOLAR WITH WIND
ENERGY AT NIGHT WHEN THE SUN IS
DOWN. IT WILL ADD THOUSANDS OF
HIGHLY SKILLED JOBS IN SUPPLY
CHAIN DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
MODELING BY THE SP ONE HUNDRED
JOINT AGENCY REPORT SHOWED THAT
WITHOUT OFFSHORE WIND TOTAL
ENERGY COSTS BECOMES ONE
BILLION DOLLARS MORE EXPENSIVE
BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE. BECAUSE
OFFSHORE WIND ALLOW RENEWABLES
TO MEET ENERGY MAN DURING ALL
HOURS. ALL AROUND THE YEAR.
THIS WILL MAKE SURE WE TAP INTO
ALL THE BENEFITS OF OFFSHORE
WIND BY GIVING WHILE GIVING
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION TO OUR
STATE'S MARINE AND COASTAL
ECOSYSTEMS AND PRIORITIZING
DEVELOPMENT IN AREAS OF LEAST
CONFLICT. WITH THAT I LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO OUR MAIN
WITNESSES LAURA HAHN WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. AND
JEREMY SMITH WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES. SO WE HAVE TWO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE AGAIN OUR POLICIES
THREE MINUTES. UP ORGANIZE
PRESENTATIONS WILL SPLIT. THAT
BETWEEN THE SPEAKERS LAURA THE
HAND WILL HAVE A MINUTE AND A
HALF CENTURY MISS. JEREMY SMITH
MINUTE HALF. MISTY HAND IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE READY TO
SPEAK. I'M HERE CHAIRMAN RICE
SO AND THEN THE NUMBER TWO AND
I'M ALREADY HOME STATE DIRECTOR
AT ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. AND
WE ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
EIGHTY FIVE TO FIVE SO THAT WE
CAN KICK START OFF SHORE WIND
OFF THE CALIFORNIA COAST. THE
REASON HEAT WAVES WILDFIRES AND
THE CURRENT DRIVE EMERGENCY
UNDERSCORED THE NEED TO
ACCELERATE OUR TRANSITION. TO A
1100% CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY AND
ONE OF THE BACK CLEAN ENERGY
SOURCES THAT WE HAVE AT OUR
DISPOSAL IS THE WIND BLOWING
OFF OUR COAST SH WHERE THE WIND
BLOWS FASTER AND HARDER THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE UNITED
STATES. OUR RECENT REPORT
OFFSHORE WIND FOR AMERICA AND
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
TECHNICAL POTENTIAL COULD MEET
MORE THAN ONE AND A HALF. OUR
ENTIRE STATE ELECTRICITY NEEDS
FROM TWENTY NINETEEN JACK FROM
OFFSHORE WIND. EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE WILL CATALYZE
CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIAL
PRODUCTION BY DIRECTING THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
COORDINATE WITH THE RELEVANT
STATE AGENCIES. ARTICLE AND
CREATE A PLAN TO PULL BACK ON
OFF SHORE WIND POWER PROTECTING
OUR CRITICAL MARINE ECOSYSTEM
SHOULD CONTACT EIGHT FIVE
DIVERSITY AND THE FASTER WE CAN
MOVE TO THE CLOUD CLEAN ENERGY
AND FAT AS- BURNING FOSSIL
FUELS THE BAXTER COUNTY ALL
HAVE FOR THE FUTURE. I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK HER AND I
TOLD. THE YOU KNOW WILL MOVE TO
YOUR SPAIN THANK HERE IN THE
HOTEL. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WE'RE PLEASED TO PARTNER WITH
OUR ALLIES AND FRIENDS IN
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIANS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
COLLECTIVELY OUR UNIONS
REPRESENT NEARLY HALF A MILLION
HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
ACROSS THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY INCLUDING MORE THAN
SIXTY THOUSAND FURNACES. OF THE
MORE THAN EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
AND THE INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY
ENROLLED OR GRADUATED FROM A
UNION AFFILIATED PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF COME
FROM COMMITTEES OF COLOR THAT
PORTION IS GROWING.
ADDITIONALLY WITH A 93% OF ALL
CURRENTLY A ROLL ON ROLL THE
READY WHEN YOU PARTICIPATE IN
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE IN EVERY CORNER OF
THE STATE. OF CALIFORNIA GOING
TRADES AMID THE FOREFRONT OF
REAL ENERGY PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA BUILDING A PORTFOLIO
OF ENERGY THAT SETS THE BAR FOR
THE REST OF THE NATION. OUR
JOURNEYMEN JOURNEY WOMEN THIS
IS A BUILT A VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S UTILITY SCALE
SOLAR WIND SOLAR EXCUSE ME BUT
WIND SOLAR HYDRO. AND
GEOTHERMAL PROJECTS ACROSS
STATE. OUR ON KNOWLEDGE OF
PRODUCTION CALIPH. MAKES US.
AWARE OF THE STRAY ON OUR
EXISTING POWER GRID AND THE
NEED TO ADD MORE FORMS OF
ENERGY TO IT. ALTHOUGH MANY
SEEM FOCUSED ON PREMATURELY
REMOVING TRADITIONAL FORMS OF
POWER. PRODUCTION MARGARET
DECEMBER SHE WAS RIGHTLY
FOCUSED ON HOW TO INCREASE
POWER PRODUCTION BY HARNESSING
CALIFORNIA'S INFINITE WIND
RESOURCE. HIGHLY TRAINED
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS AND
APPRENTICES PLAY A PIVOTAL ROLE
IN BALANCING THE ENERGY NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA BY MAINTAINING
INSTALLING ALL TYPES OF POWER
INFRASTRUCTURE. THESE BLUE
COLLAR JOBS RIGHT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF OUR MEMBERS FAMILY
SITTING WAGES. AND MIDDLE CLASS
EXISTENCE WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO SEEING OUR MEMBERS OUR
FRIENDS WORK. ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL ENABLE
CALIFORNIA. TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE TOTAL MOBILE POWER
PORTFOLIO. MAKING OUR STATE
EVEN MORE GREEN IN OUR GREAT
MORE RELIABLE. THIS BILL IS A
WIN WIN WE URGE RIVAL TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL-
MOVED TO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL IF WE HAVE ANYONE
HERE IN THE GALLERY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. YOU CAN SIR. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBER SCOTT WHICH ON
BEHALF THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. OKAY DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE NO
ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE GALLERY. WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. FIVE TWENTY
FIVE. MODERATOR PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FIVE TWENTY FIVE. YEAH IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FREE INTERNET
ON BEHALFOF SERIES AND
SUSTAINABLE NONPROFIT THAT RUNS
BUSINESS FOR INNOVATIVE CLIMATE
AND ENERGY POLICY NETWORK A
COALITION OF SEVENTY BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE US. IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WELL NOT SPEAKER. ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF THE
TENETS OF AMERICAN MONEY
COLLECTED ATTEND EXAMINER THE
CHRONICLE SPONSORED AB FIVE TO
FIVE AND FRESHLY AFTER I BOOK
TODAY THANK YOU. THE NEXT
SPEAKER. ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS REALLY A BARRACK ON BEHALF
OF THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION FOR. NEXT
BECAUSE- NINE THIRTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTEZ WITH
GOVERNMENTAL ADVOCATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. NEXT PICKER. FINE
TWENTY FOUR. SURE BRUCE
MCDONALD SACRAMENTAL ACT AND
THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO
TOGETHER- IN SUPPORT. NEXT
FIGURE. THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBER DANIELLE MAIL ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN CLEAN
POWER CALIFORNIA HERE TO OFFER
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
FIVE BEEN ABLE TO ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENTAL AND RELIABILITY
BENEFITS THAT OFFSHORE WIND CAN
PROVIDE I ALSO WANT TO CONVEY
SUPPORT FROM THE BROADER
OFFSHORE WIND INDUSTRY- SO READ
A LIST OF OTHER INDUSTRY
SUPPORTERS WHICH INCLUDE AKHIR
OFFSHORE WIND SHEAR STRATEGIES
LLC. BUSINESS NETWORK FOR
OFFSHORE WIND KATELYN EDF
RENEWABLE BACK WHEN OUR
MAGELLAN WHEN MAINSTREAM
RENEWABLE POWER OPTION WHEN
OFFSHORE WIND CALIFORNIA OR BAD
FOR THE GOSHEN ENERGY TRUST
PRINTABLE POWER. AND R. W. E.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT BIG.
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBER ONE JOB IN THE
POLITICAL SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
B. P. AMERICA CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. FIND. FORTY FIVE.
LINE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH A YOUNG EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF BRIGHTLINE AND SNOW
BY MENTAL JUSTICE ORIENTATION
AND SUPPORT. NEXT PICKER. LINE.
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU- THE LAST
TEN YEARS ON BEHALF OF THREE
SIXTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
SUPPORT THANKS. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. FIND SIXTY THREE.
REMEMBER TWENTY THREE WITH THE
WHITE MAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
THE FAITH COMMUNITY ENERGY AND
TRANSPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. SIXTY SEVEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WILL BE ASKED
TO LEAVE SHOP ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
COUNTY OF SAN LUIS OBISPO AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE COUNTY OF
HUMBOLDT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. NINE SIXTY EIGHT.
DR NADIA LINES OF NURSES FOR
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU- NEXT BIGGER. NINE
SIXTY NINE. REMINDER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
TWENTY OR SO SHE SAID WELL IT'S
MCP SEVEN CUSTOMER NUMBER AND
NUMBER AND COUNTRY CUTS THAT IN
NAPA COUNTY THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU THE NEXT BIGGER. LINE
SEVENTY THREE. AN AFTERNOON
HEARING MEMBERS AARON RODRIGUEZ
ENOUGH CONCERNS I HAVE RIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. AND MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
ELSE HAS SIGNALED. OKAY VERY
WELCOME TWO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION TO HAVE ANYONE HERE
IN THE GALLERY THAT WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION TO AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE. ANYONE A ROOM
ONE TWELVE NINE NOBODY APPEARS
TO BE ROOM ONE TWELVE WE'LL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR-
COULD YOU- WE DON'T HAVE ANY-
ORGANIZE PRESENTATIONS IN
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO. SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION OF A. B. FIVE
TWENTY FIVE MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF. FIVE TWENTY
FIVE. AN APPARITION OF FIVE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE ELSE
HAS SIGNALED. OKAY WILL COME TO
THE FLOOR NOW WE HAVE A CENTER
MEN. AND FOLLOWED BY CENTER
BECKER FOLLOWED BY SOONER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANT TO PLUG THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS- VERY
THOUGHTFUL FRAMEWORK FOR. WIND
I KNOW HE'S BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR AWHILE. I THINK THIS
IS POTENTIALLY A GAME CHANGER
AND IT. IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
AWFUL IT BRINGS TOGETHER THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS IN A WAY
THAT I THINK IS CREATES A VERY
SUSTAINABLE- OFFERING MORE
AGAIN I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
VS ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
EARLIEST OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER. WHEN I
THINK THE AUTHOR AS WELL IN
ORDER TO BE A CO AUTHOR HERE
JUST THREE QUICK POINTS THAT
OFFSHORE WIND IS. ACTUALLY
CRUCIAL TO MEETING OUR CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS OF A 100% CLEAN
ENERGY SECONDLY THAT WITHOUT
OFFSHORE WIND IT WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXPENSIVE TO
DO SO. AND THIRD IS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONS WITH THE POTENTIAL TO
CREATE A NEW EXPORT INDUSTRY
FOR THIS STATE AS WEST COAST
CENTER FOR MANUFACTURING PORT
FACILITIES INSTALLATION
EXPERTISE. WHICH CAN DRIVE NEW-
COULD PAY WELL PAID JOBS SO
I'M- UNDER SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. CENTER REDFORD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AND I TO SUPPORT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY THE TECHNOLOGY
IN THE PROMISE OF OFFSHORE WIND
I'VE SEEN IT WORK AGAIN OVER IN
EUROPE SO IT'S NO DOUBT THAT
THE TECHNOLOGY. TIME HAS COME
MY CONCERN HERE IS ALWAYS THE
PROMISE. OF JOBS AND- AND
PROMISE OF A DIVERSE WORKFORCE
MAPPED. A INDIVIDUAL WHO SPENT
CLOSE TO TWENTY YEARS IN THE
ENERGY SECTOR. THE PROMISE OF
DIVERSE JOBS HAS NOT YET TO
ARRIVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA OR
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY. THE ART
PORTFOLIO HAS DIVERSIFIED OUR
WORKFORCE HASN'T SHOW. ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO PROMISE
JOBS THEY HAVE TO BE REAL AND
WE GOT TO QUIT USING. PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND POOR FOLKS AS A
REASON WHY WE DO MOST OF THESE
THINGS WHEN THEY VERY RARELY IF
EVER. BENEFIT FROM ANY OF THESE
JOBS AND I HOPE THAT A EUROPEAN
CONT COMPANY. IS OUR GOAL I
QUESTION IF THEY'RE FAR MORE
COMMITTED TO DIVERSITY HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY THAN THEY ARE IN
THEIR OWN BUT- HOPEFULLY- YOU
CAN PROVE ME WRONG BUT- I
SUPPORT THE TECHNOLOGY BUT
AGAIN. I HOPE THE JOBS ARE
REALITY BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T SEEN
IN A WIND AND SOLAR INDUSTRY
SO- HOPEFULLY WE CAN SEE IT IN
OFF SHORE WHERE. ANYONE ELSE TO
HAVE A MOTION. SENATOR DODD-
MAKES A MOTION MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER-
THE CENTER RUBIO DID YOU WANNA
MAKE A COMMENT. YES THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR I THINK THAT
YOU NOW THIS BILL WILL BRING A
LOT IMMEDIATE BENEFITS BUT ALSO
LONG TERM BENEFITS AND I THINK
JUST TOPPED BUT GOOD PAYING
JOBS THAT IT WILL PRODUCES
BENEFIT IN ITSELF BUT YOU KNOW
ALSO MEETING OUR CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO.
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR THANK
YOU. DID YOU WANNA MAKE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS CENTER
TEACHER. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
FIRST OF ALL LET ME JUST THANK
OUR OUR SENATORS FROM SILICON
VALLEY FIRST EARLY SUPPORT I'M
HAPPYTO ADD AS CO AUTHORS- HER
SENATE COLLEAGUES FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND SAN GABRIEL VALLEY-
TO THE CENTER FROM LOS ANGELES
LET ME JUST SAY. I ABSOLUTELY
SHARE YOUR- STRONG INTEREST AND
THE INTEREST OF OUR STATED
ENSURING THAT HAS RECORDING
THESE JOBS WERE PUTTING
EVERYONE TO WORK NOT JUST SOME
FOLKS TO WORK. AND I KNOW
YOU'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK ON.
UTILITY SUPPLIER DIVERSITY AND
I APPLAUD THAT I WANT TO JUST
POINT OUT THAT IN THIS BILL-
THERE ARE PROVISIONS THAT HAS
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. PLANS FOR THIS
PARTICULAR AROUND WORK FORCE
THAT THEY LOOK AT. HOW WE HAVE
TARGETED HIRING STANDARDS WHICH
REALLY IS LOOKING AT THE
DIVERSITY OF THIS FUTURE WORK
FORCE WE WANNA MAKE SURE- THAT
IF WE ARE SUCCESSFUL HERE-
WE'RE PUTTING EVERY ASPECT OF
OUR COMMUNITIES TO WORK AND
DOING THAT IN A NEW WAY AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. WITH THE JUST
TRANSITION AND I. I JUST THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WE WILL CERTAINLY BE
MONITORING TO SEE OTHER
NONSENSE- AS THIS PROCEEDS-
ELSE WANNA JUST TAKE A MOMENT
AND THANK THE TREMENDOUS
COALITION OF LABOR.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CLEAN ENERGY
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE'VE HAD
FOR THIS. THIS IS- OFFSHORE
WIND HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
REALLY TRANSFORM OUR STATE.
WITH ENORMOUS ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC BENEFITS. IT'S GOING
TO TAKE A LOT OF WORK BUT IT'S
GOT TO START WITH THEM WITH
PLANNING- AND REALLY THINKING
HOLISTICALLY ABOUT HOW WE PUT
CALIFORNIA ON THE MAP.
PARTICULARLY AT A TIME WHEN
OTHER STATES AND OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE FAR AHEAD OF US-
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD QUICKLY
AND HOPEFULLY WITH THIS BILL WE
CAN DO THAT- AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
SUPPORT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. K. VERY WELL THE
THIRD NO MOVED FURTHER
COMMENTS- WE HAVE A MOTION.
ONCE AGAIN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS A ROUTE RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
ON WATER CENTER I'M SORRY
SECRETARY- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHTY FIVE TO FIVE BEISEL
NUMBER JUDY PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER WESSEL.
WESSEL HI DOLLY. DOLLY HI
BECKER ALL RIGHT BECKER HI FOR
JUST. BRADFORD PARK BRADFORD HI
DOT HI DON HI IGMAN HI AIKMAN
HI GONZALEZ HI THEMSELVES HIGH
GROWTH. HURT SPURRED BY
HERZBERG HI MIKE WEIR. MAN MAN
HI RUBIO HI RUBIO HI STERN. THE
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF
INFRACTION MEMBERS THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER THANK YOU
SENATORS NOW WE'RE GONNA GO ON
TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE. WHICH IS-
A. B. SIX FORTY ONE BY- SIMPLY
GERMAN HOLDEN. A BILL HAVING TO
DO WITH- PUBLICLY ONLY ELECTRIC
UTILITIES. BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE BEFORE
YOU TODAY MEMBERS I FIRST LIKE
TO START. BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS- TODAY.
AND TO THINK THAT YOU'RE IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ATTENTION AND DEDICATION TO
IMPROVING THE SPELL. AS WE HAVE
SEEN DEMAND FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES IS GROWING. WE HAVE A
SET GOAL IN THE STATE OF FIVE
MILLION EV'S BY TWENTY THIRTY
WHICH MEANS WE'LL NEED OVER ONE
MILLION SHARED CHARGERS TO COME
ON LINE ACROSS THE STATE. BUILD
OUT OF THE V. CHARGERS IS
OCCURRING IN MANY AREAS BUT WE
ARE RELYING HEAVILY ON THE
STATE'S ELECTRIC I'LL USE TO
FILL THIS NEED. WE MUST BE SURE
THAT PO USER FILLING THE GAP IN
THEIR TERRITORIES AS WELL. AS
THEY SERVE A THIRD OF OUR
STATE'S ELECTRIC CUSTOMERS.
THIS BILL WOULD DO JUST THAT BY
REQUIRING ALL PEOPLE USED TO
INSURE PUBLIC CHARGING IS
AVAILABLE IN THEIR TERRITORIES
AND IT GIVES THEM FULL ATTITUDE
ON HOW THEY MAKE THAT HAPPEN
INCLUDING CHARGING FOR THE
SERVICE OR WORKING WITH PRIVATE
INDUSTRY. TO FILL THE NEED
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
ON EIGHTY SIX FORTY ONE. AND WE
HAVE SOME- SPEAKERS- IN AN
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION- WE HAVE
IN SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION.
WE'LL BEGIN WITHIN SUPPORT WE
HAVE A SCOTT WHAT'S LISTED AS A
SPEAKER. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOT WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS CAN YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. AS YOU KNOW- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- PLANS TO
SPEND A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY ON CONTINUING TO EXPAND
THE T. V- INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED NUMEROUS
BILLS- DIRECTING THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES TO BUILD OUT
THEIR TEARS SERVICE TERRITORIES
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT AS YOU KNOW
WE HAVE GREAT SWATHS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHICH ARE
COVERED BY MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
AND MANY OF THOSE AREAS ARE
IMPOVERISHED- IN BOTH RURAL AND
URBANIZED- TERRITORIES. IT'S
REALLY ESSENTIAL THAT THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES INVEST.
ESPECIALLY IF WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE A STATE
WOULD HAVE AND HAVE NOTS AND
THEN ALL OF THOSE- AREAS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HAVE
CHARGING STATIONS FOR PEOPLE OF
ALL ECONOMIC STATUS AND THAT'S
WHAT WE FEEL LIKE THIS SIX
FORTY ONE IS AN IMPORTANT BILL
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL GO
TO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT HERE IN
THE GALLERY DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT. OF A. B. SIX FORTY
ONE ANYONE. BUT WE'LL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE- NOBODY'S IN
ONE TWELVE WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE CUES SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OF SB. SIX FORTY ONE. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX
FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
ACTED UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY
VERY WELL WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE AN
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION MADE UP
OF TWO SPEAKERS. WE HAVE A
GREAT COOK AND WE ALSO HAVE
PATRICK WELL WE'RE GOING TO
WELSH WILL SPLIT YOUR THREE
MINUTES INTO A MINUTE AND A
HALF. IS A GREAT COOK ON THE
LINE. MISTER CHAIR YOU HAVE A
MINUTE AND A HALF PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
THIS IS GREG COOK REPRESENTING
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY. CALIFORNIA'S PUBLICLY
OWNED ELECTRIC UTILITY SUPPORT
THE STATE'S ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE ACCELERATION PLAN. AND
THE AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ARE
SIGNIFICANT STEP IN ACHIEVING
THE SUCCESS OF THAT PLAN. WE
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF SB
EIGHTY SIX FORTY ONE AND THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL ASSIST US IN
COMPLYING WITH THE SPIRIT AND
THE LETTER OF THE LEGISLATION.
I WANT TO THANK YU CHIP AWAY
SO. THE ENERGY COMMITTEE STAFF
AND SOME OF THEM HOLDING FOR
CONSIDERING THE CONCERNS THAT
WE PRESENTED REGARDING THIS
BILL AND WITH THE ADOPTION OF
THE AMENDMENTS TODAY. NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IS
PLEASED TO WITHDRAW ITS
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THAT PATRICK PATRICK WELCH. YES
THANK YOU MR CHAIR. PATRICK
WHAT CAN BE OUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION. NOT AN OPPOSING
POSITION BUT WE DID FILE A
LETTER OF CONCERN PREVIOUSLY
SPECIFICALLY IMMUNIZED CONCERNS
WERE ABOUT THE WORD INSURER IN
THE TAIL WHEN IT COMES TO THE
OBLIGATIONS OF LOCAL PUBLICLY
OWNED ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING SECTOR. WE
BELIEVE THAT MA'AM AND
SUGGESTED BY THE MANY ANALYSIS
AND ACCEPTED BY THE AUTHOR
TODAY IMPROVED THE BILL WE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR- THE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR
WORKING TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN AND LIKE THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POWER AGENCY ESTIMATED MEMBERS
SUPPORT A LACK EDUCATION OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND WE- FIVE THANK
EVERYONE. FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
STOCK THANK YOU. K. VERY WELL
AND I WANTED FOR THE-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN MISTER
CHAIRMAN I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE- WE GET ON THE RECORD YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
AMENDMENTS YES OKAY I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT WILL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION- AND
AGAIN- ANYONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION. OF
EIGHTY SIX FORTY ONE. ANYONE IN
ROOM TWELVE NO ONE IS PRESENT
ROOM TWELVE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF. EIGHTY SIX FORTY
ONE. AN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
SIX FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE HAS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. VERY WELLTHANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR WILL COME TO THE
FLOOR NOT US TO TWO SENATORS IF
THERE ANY COMMENTS. ATTENTION
MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR BRADFORD DID YOU WANNA
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL AND I
THINK THE AMENDMENTS- ARE VERY
FINE AND DO THE RIGHT JOB AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AND THE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADDED IN
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE- SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION AND THEN WE-
HAVE AGREED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
HAVE THOSE MOMENTS. IN
TRANSPORTATION. AND THAT IS-
THE WILL OF THIS BODY-
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE VOTE. MAYBE SIX FOUR ONE BY
PHONE NUMBER HOLD IN TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON TRANSPORTATION WESSEL. BYE
WESSEL HI SALLY A BOEING.
CERTAINLY NOT HOLDING. BAKER
BAKER HI FORTUS. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I THOUGHT I THOUGHT HI
AIKMAN HI AIKMAN I WANT ALL
THIS HI THIS IS ALICE HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG
I REQUIRE. MEN ARE MEN HI RUBIO
HI RUBIO HI STERN. THE BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT WILL
HOLD A REAL OPEN FRAPPES
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
SOME LIVER HOLDEN I WILL GO OUT
TO ITEM NUMBER SIX NOW BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS IN THE
ROOM. ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES IN
THE ROOM NOW.
THANK.
WE'RE
GONNA CALL ABSENT MEMBERS ON
BILLS WHILE WE WAIT FOR SOME A
MEMBER RADIUS- WE'RE GONNA TAKE
UP ITEM NUMBER. ONE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN. IF THE SECRETARY CAN
CALL THE UPS MEMBERS ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE A. B. FOURTEEN BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUILAR CURRY.
MAYBE FOURTEEN BY SEVEN MEMBER
AGUILAR CARRIED TO PASS AS
AMENDED. GORGEOUS GROSS.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY REQUIRE.
WE'LL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER TWO
A. B. FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE OPTION NUMBERS.
AB FORTY ONE BY SOME MEMBER
WOULD DO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
PORTIS. GROSS REQUIRE. WE'LL
TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B.
THREE TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS.
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY TWO BY
SEVEN MARCELLUS DID PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BARGES. GROSS
REQUIRE STERN. STERN HI. SOME
OF THE MEMBER AS YOU'RE HERE I
HAVE TO SAY YOU LOST SOME
POINTS BYE BYE BYE BEEN A
LITTLE TARDY BUT YOU CAN MAKE A
MONTH BY REVEALING YOUR
COMMENTS. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MR CHAIR.
MY APOLOGIES FOR. THREE
TARDINESS BUT TODAY I PRESENT
TO YOU A B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE WHICH WILL MODERNIZE THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION'S
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
BY REVISING THE PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS IN
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
AND INVESTMENTS IN OUR MOST
POLLUTED AREAS. THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAS BEEN
A CRUCIAL TOOL TO ADVANCE CLEAN
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE PROGRAM
RECEIVES APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
IN TECHNOLOGY AND FUEL NOTE IS
TECHNOLOGY AND FUEL NEUTRAL AND
IS MEANT TO DEPLOY INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT TRANSFORM
CALIFORNIA'S FUEL AND VEHICLE
TYPES. THE PROGRAM WAS LAST
UPDATED IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. AND SINCE THEN THERE
HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF CLIMATE
POLICIES. AND DEVELOPMENTS IN
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY THAT WORE THE
DISCUSSION OF THE PRIORITIES OF
THIS PROGRAM. ABC THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE WORLD CORPORATE
PROGRAM CHANGES. THAT WILL
FOCUS INVESTMENTS IN ADDRESSING
INFRASTRUCTURE GAPS IN THE
CLEAN LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE MARKET.
SUPPORT THE EMERGING CLEAN
MEDIUM AND DUTY MEDIUM HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE INDUSTRY. DEDICATE
50% OF FUNDING TO PROJECTS
LOCATED IN AN BENEFITING A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
PROVIDE PREFERENCES FOR
PROJECTS THAT REDUCE CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS IN OUR MOST POLLUTED
AREAS. CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF
THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE
COUNTRY SOME **** VALLEY THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND THE GREATER
LOS ANGELES AREA. ARE CURRENTLY
CLASSIFIED AS EXTREME NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS UNDER THE
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT. MANY
OTHER PARTS OFTHE STATE SUCH
AS THE BAY AREA SACRAMENTO AND
SAN DIEGO. RANGING FROM
MODERATE TO SEVERE NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS. CALIFORNIA
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A LEADER IN
ADDRESSING THEIR QUALITY BUT
IT'S CLEAR THAT MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE. CLEANING UP THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS
CRITICAL TO DEMONSTRATING THE
REQUIREMENT OF JUSTICE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT NOT ONLY
CAN CO EXIST. BUT ARE
COMPLEMENTARY TO EACH OTHER.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TODAY R. DAN HOWLS
WITH CAL START. AND THE MILES
SMALLER WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. OKAY
WE WILL HEAR FROM THE SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT THERE ARE NO
SPEAKERS IN OUR- IN AN
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. WILL
SPLIT THE THREE MINUTES BY EACH
SPEAKER THERAPY A MINUTE AND A
HALF FOR SPEAKER BEGINNING WITH
THAT HOUSE. SCHRODER COMMUTER
HORRIBLE AND MEMBERS UNDER
HOUSE TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
CAL START HERE AS THE SPONSOR
OF AB THIRTEEN AND I. FIRST
WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO THE
AUTHOR AND FINISHER AFFABLE
WORKED VERY HARD ON THIS POLICY
NOT TO GET IT TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY. L. SERVED AS A MEMBER
BASED NONPROFIT WITH OVER TWO
HUNDRED SEMI MEMBER COMPANIES
DEDICATED TO TRANSFORMING THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY. OUR
MEMBERSHIP IS COMPRISED OF
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS AND ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY ON
ALTERNATE FUEL PRODUCERS PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE PLATES AND MORE.
HERE'S THE COMMISSION'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS THAT A
CRITICAL ELEMENT OF OUR SPEECH
TESTING REQUIREMENT PROGRAMS IT
IS A TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT HAS HELPED TO
ADVANCE VEHICLE. AND FUELING
TECHNOLOGIES. HOWEVER THE STAY
HAS POW MEDICAL LAW SINCE
PROGRESS FOR SHALL ALMOST A
YEARS. AND THERE'S BEEN MANY
DEVELOPMENTS TRYING I MISS YOUR
OMISSION VEHICLE FRONTS. YOU'RE
FORTY REALITY THAT WOULD MAKE
SENSE TO MODIFY THE STATUTE
GUIDING THESE PROGRAMS AND SURE
THAT REFLECTS OUR CURRENT GOALS
AS WELL AS RECENT TECHNOLOGICAL
DEVELOPMENTS AND MARKET TRENDS
SH THIS BILL DOES THAT WHILE
BRINGING TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL.
FOR EXAMPLE WE NEED TO RAPIDLY
SCALE UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES WHICH WILL
BEGIN EXPEDITIOUSLY COMING TO
MARKET DUE TO THE ADVANCE CLEAN
TRUCKS ROLL AND OTHER CAR BREAK
ELATION EACH. IT IS ALSO-
PROVIDES INCENTIVES TO DO IT
TWO FIVE FOUR DOUBLE LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES AS WELL. MORE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ON THE BILL
ADDRESS WE NEED TO ENSURE
EQUITABLE ACTIONS CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
TRANSPORTATION MATURING THAT
50% OF THE PROGRAM FUNDS WILL
BENEFIT. DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BY REPLACING OLD.
SHOOTING DO YOU DIESEL
VEHICLES. OUT AND FOCUSING ON
CHARGING OR REFUELING- FOR
CLEAN VEHICLES I AM VERY MUCH
EXPANSIONIST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HEALTHCARE FOR MILES
SMALLER. NOW A MINUTE AND A
HALF MR MILLER. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN OF MILD MILLER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL AND ALSO
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF OUR
PARTNERS IN THE CHARGE HAD
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN. INCLUDING
THE COALITION BETWEEN ARAB
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA AND THE REMAINING IN
THE GAME ALL INSTRUCTED. BY
DEFLATION. THIS BILL WOULD
MODERNIZE THE CALIFORNIA YOU
COMMISSION THE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM TO INCORPORATE THE
LEADER. OF OUR MENTAL GOLDEN
REMOTE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
INVESTMENT. PROJECTS EVER GET
HARMFUL CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS
AND TOXIC. EMISSIONS
OVERBURDENED COMMUNITIES. WE
ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE THE
STRONG EQUITY COMPONENT OF THE
BILL THAT WOULD ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING WILL BENEFIT ARE
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THINGS LIKE
REPLACING POLLUTING DIESEL
VEHICLES WITH ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. AND APPOINT PUBLICLY
ACCEPTABLE REVEALING OR
CHARGING STATIONS. SERVING LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS. BECAUSE ALL
CALIFORNIA THEIR DAD CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY ACT. THAT
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY HERE TODAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE GALLERY DO
WE HAVE ANY SPEAKERS AND
SUPPORT NO ONE HERE. HOW ABOUT
A ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. LE. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE. TWENTY ONE THEN. RICHER
MOBILE TO LINE SEVENTY NINE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STILL THE
ANTILLES SHANTI HALF OF THE
DANCE ENERGY ECONOMY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE NEXT
PICKER. NEXT BAKER. SEVEN THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE NUMBERS AARON
RODRIGUEZ UNITS CAN VERIFY AND
SUPPORT YEAH THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. SEVENTY FOUR. BREANNA
PANETTA ON BEHALF OF THE SERIES
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION ABB HVC COMPANY
AMPLY POWERED ANAHEIM
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK AND-
VALLEY TRANSIT AUTHORITY
ARRIVAL SOLID SALAD OUR SYSTEM
CHANGE ENERGY E. NOW GREENPOWER
MOTOR COMPANY JB POINDEXTER AND
COMPANY MOMENTUM DYNAMICS CORP
CORPORATION MOTIV POWER SYSTEMS
THE COLA CORPORATION- DYING
DONE. PHOENIX MOTORCARS. ERA
SEE A- SOMEONE TRANSIT AGENCY
USING THE ONLINE ELECTRIC
COMPANY HELLO SAY ENERGY VOLVO
GROUP NORTH AMERICA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. NINE
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
CHRIS POWER ON BEHALF OF OBERON
FUELS IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. MISTER
CHAIR NO ONE HAS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY WE'LL
GO TO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SPEAKERS HERE IN THE GALLERY
AND OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE
SPEAKER. THANK YOU SENATOR
TERESA CUTLER- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS EFFORTS TO
MAKE THE BILL TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL BUT WHAT HASN'T BEEN
RECOGNIZED IS THE DOZENS OF
POLICIES AND FINANCING
MECHANISMS. PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE LAST DECADE
THAT ARE EXCLUSIVELY LIMITED TO
CHARGING FOR BETTER FOR WORSE
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM IS THE ONLY PROGRAM
THAT INCLUDES HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WITHOUT
DIRECTION TO THE CVC TO FINISH
DEVELOPING THE HYDROGEN FUELING
NETWORK UNFORTUNATELY WE RISK
PROVIDING ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
ACCESS. TO THOSE LIVING IN
MULTI FAMILY DWELLINGS ARE
SUPER COMMUTERS AND THOSE OF US
THAT ARE IN SINGLE VEHICLE
HOUSEHOLDS FOR THOSE REASONS WE
OPPOSE THE I. EIGHTY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE UNLESS AMENDED TO
ALLOW FOR THE BUILD OUT OF THE
REMAINING THREE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THE LADY TO HYDROGEN
MARKET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
ANY SPEAKERS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
IN OPPOSITION. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WILL
COME TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR. COULD YOU PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF A
BEETLE THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE. AN
APPARITION OF THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE HAS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WOULD ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HI ISIS KOLOGI SCENE AT
THE ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION- WE'RE SUPER
SPECTRALLY- POSE IN LAS AMENDED
ON THE BILL. CURRENTLY THERE IS
NO REQUIREMENT FOR LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES- INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING THAT DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THE FEES PAID. FOR THESE
PROGRAMS- AND THAT REVENUE ARE
GENERATED BY LIGHT DUTY-
VEHICLE OWNERS. THE STATE IN
THE ENERGY COMMISSION HAS
INDICATED AT ONE POINT TWO
MILLION CHARGES ARE NEEDED.
BANNON BACKED UC DAVIS SAYS
THAT 20% OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE OWNERS DID NOT
REPURCHASE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
BECAUSE OF LACK OF ACCESS. TO
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING SO WE
AGAIN ARE ASKING. FOR A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF THIS REVENUE TO
BE SPENT ON THIS CRITICAL NEED
IF WE'RE GOING TO MEET OUR
STATED MISSION GOALS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU IN A MODERATOR PLEASE
CHOOSE THE NEXT SPEAKER AND
PLEASE- LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. YOUR
NAME AND ANY AFFILIATION
MODERATOR. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
HAD ALFA SIGNALED. OKAY VERY
WELL WILL COME TO THE COMMITTEE
IF THERE ARE ANY COMMENTS FROM.
THE SENATORS CENTER GONZALEZ.
YES I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
CARRYING THE COMPANION BILL TO
THIS- TO THIS- EFFORT HERE IN
THE SENATE- AND I KNOW SHE AND
SHE IS COMMITTED. TO ENSURING
THAT THERE IS A DIVERSE
PORTFOLIO OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ARE NEUTRAL. BUT WITH AN EQUITY
FOCUS FIRST WHICH I THINK IS
BOTH WHAT WE ARE INCLINED TO DO
SO WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE
AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION- DID
YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS SOME OF THE MEMBER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE BY FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS DID PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON TRANSPORTATION WESSEL HI
WHAT'S UP HI DOLLY. YOU KNOW
BECKER RIGHT FACTOR FIVE
ORANGES NO FOR JUST NOW
BRADFORD. RECORD I THOUGHT I'D
DONE HI EIGHT MEN HI AIKMAN HI
GONZALEZ I CONSULTED HI HELLO.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY MCGUIRE.
MAN HI MAN HI RUBIO HI RUBIO HI
STERN. STERN BY. THE BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT OF.
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN AT THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE PATEL WILL COME ACK TO
FOR A. B. FIVE TWENTY FIVE. IF
YOU COULD PLEASE CALL THE UPS
MEMBERS MA'AM SECRETARY. WITH
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
PORTIS. GORGEOUS HIGH GROWTH.
MIKE WEIR. STERN STERN HI. THE
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT WORLD. WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN- WE'LL GO TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE A. B. SIX FORTY ONE TO
CALL THE UPS MEMBERS. FABI SIX
FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN'S DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION DOLLY. BURGESS
NO BORDERS NO. HELLO REQUIRE.
CERN II STERN I. IT WILL KEEP
THE ROAD OPEN FOR THE UP TO
MEMBERS. ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
HERE THAT- DID NOT THE POLICE
CONTINUE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
VOTE ON A BILL THAT THEY
HAVEN'T VOTED ON. OKAY. SENATOR
STERN. IF POSSIBLE TO CHANGE MY
VOTE I THINK I ALREADY VOTED ON
AN ITEM THEY DID NOT NEED TO
VOTE ON MY OWN WHICH ONE IS A-
THREE TWENTY TWO I THINK IT'S
FIVE ITEMS. THREE BONAVA AB
THREE TWENTY TWO- MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU CALL. THE
ROLE ON THE BILL. EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY TWO BY SOME MEMBER
SILENCE. THE PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FOR JUST. FORTIS
HI. GROSS MCGUIRE. STERN STERN
I DID NOW. OKAY ANYONE ELSE-
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS AN
ITEM NUMBER ONE. AP FOURTEEN BY
SEVEN MEMBER ID ARE CURRY THE
PASS AS AMENDED. FORTUS GROSS
REQUIRE I REQUIRE HI. ON ITEM
TO PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS
PLEASE. AB FORTY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER WHAT THE PASS. FORTIS.
GROVE MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE HI ONE
ITEM NUMBER THREE PLEASE CALL
THE UPS AND MEMBERS. EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY TWO BY SOMEONE
OVER SILAS TO PASS. GROSS
REQUIRE I REQUIRE I. A ROOM
NUMBER FOUR PLEASE CALL THE UPS
MEMBERS EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
BY SEVEN MEMBER TO DO PASS.
HELLO MCGUIRE HI MISFIRE HI-
REMEMBER FIVE PHYSICALLY UPSET
MEMBERS. EIGHTY SIX FORTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN'S. DO
PASS DOLLY. GROSS. MCGUIRE HI
REQUIRED HI ON ITEM NUMBER SIX
A. B. THIRTY NINE PLEASE CALL
THE UPS MEMBERS. A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE BY SOME MEMBER
RADIUS DO PASS DOLLY. HELLO MY
CHOIR BY THE CHOIR I. THIS
BRINGS US TO THE END OF OUR
AGENDA THE WORK INCLUDING THE
MEETING THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TEST MIGHT
HAVE TESTIFIED TODAY PLEASE
MAKE YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
UTILITIES OR COMMUNICATIONS. OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE POURING TO
US WE WANT TO CLOSE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PREACH
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WITH
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS IS NOW
ADJOURNED.